bonsoir à tous nous sommes le jeudi 19
novembre merci de nous retrouver pour
cette nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal
votre acuité locale chaque jour
accompagné des journalistes de la
rédaction mais aussi de nos invités tout
de suite les titres de cette édition
l'état d'urgence prolonger les centres
commerciaux renforce les contrôles
exemple à l'espace saint quentin à
montigny le bretonneux et à vélizy 2 200
logements une nouvelle école des
résidences de tourisme c'est un tout
nouveau quartier qui commencent à voir
le jour à guyancourt d'une clinique est
également annoncé pour 2016 et enfin
championnats de france juniors de judo
ce sera ce week-end au vélodrome de
montigny le bretonneux 900 combattants
sont attendus et pour commencer cette
information le préfet des yvelines vient
de recevoir à cet après midi à
versailles
l'ensemble des maires des civils une
réunion à la demande du ministre de
l'intérieur pour informer les élus des
conséquences de la prolongation de
l'état d'urgence au lendemain des
attentats salle de spectacle municipal
salle de cinéma était restée ouverte
avec un contrôle à l'entrée les
compétitions sportives avait été elle
suspendu le préfet vient de terminer son
point presse
nous vous donnerons tous les détails des
nouvelles annonces dans notre édition de
demain
à noter en tout cas que les
manifestations sur la voie publique sont
interdites dans l'ensemble de
l'ile-de-france jusqu'à dimanche soir
minuit une demande cette fois ci les la
préfecture de police de paris et enfin
suite au tragique attentat du vendredi
13 novembre à paris 150 personnes se
sont réunies à la verrière à lundi soir
en salle du conseil municipal
une façon de rendre hommage aux victimes
aux victimes des attentats et d'apporter
leur soutien aux familles et proches et
des disparus est blessé la séance s'est
terminée par la pose de bougies devant
l'hôtel de ville
élus et habitants ont affirmé via une
lettre leur volonté de se rassembler
dans les valeurs de la république et on
réfute en refusant les amalgames pour
tous les assassins du 13 novembre ne
sont pas des musulmans mais des
criminels
cela a été réaffirmé avec force par le
président de l'association des musulmans
de la verrière et un hommage qui a été
également rendu à trappes
hier soir avant le conseil
ipalle l'ensemble des élus et quelques
habitants ont déposé une gerbe et des
bougies au pied de la statue de jean
jaurès devant la mairie la ville destine
ce lieu à la mémoire des victimes des
événements dramatiques du vendredi 13
novembre les trappistes qui souhaitent
se recueillir pour moi il déposer une
fleur un dessin une photo ou encore une
bougie des banderoles ici nous vivons en
fraternité pour la paix ont été déposés
sur le pou cachin le maire a également
écrit une lettre à destination des
trappistes où il condamne les assassins
en rappelant l'importance de ne pas
faire d'amalgamé ni de céder aux dérives
racistes et un tweet qui fait également
couler beaucoup d'encre deuxième adjoint
aux finances à saint-cyr-l'ecole
frédérique et bruno blondel a publié
hier sur ce réseau social
le commentaire suivant un commentaire
qui a indigné la gauche yvelinoise qui
n'a pas manqué d'interpeller le maire de
la commune ainsi que la responsable des
républicains dans le département valérie
pécresse
réponse du principal intéressé il
s'agissait il s'agit d' un parallèle
intéressant avec la sphère julie gayet
il ajoute mes tweets n'engage que moi je
ne suis encarté ni aux républicains ni
au front national
le maire de saint cyr bernard de bain a
lui aussi publié un commentaire sur
twitter je désapprouvait les propos
privés d'un adjoint mais également la
tentative de récupération du tweet
incriminé a en tout cas été retirée
depuis
et vous savez depuis les attentats
perpétrés à paris le vendredi 13
novembre les mesures de sécurité ont été
renforcées hier nous vous parlions des
salles de cinéma mais aussi des salles
de spectacles aujourd'hui nous sommes
allés dans les centres commerciaux
adhésives in faire le point sur les
dispositifs mis en place pour assurer
votre sécurité
un reportage réalisé avec williams à
elle et patrick jacques de dixmude
samedi 14 novembre au lendemain des
attentats qui ont touché paris certains
centres commerciaux yvelinois comme
l'espace saint quentin ont fermé leurs
portes par mesure de sécurité
si dès le dimanche il a réouvert ses
clients sont maintenant contrôlé dès
leur arrivée trouve ça tout à fait
normal et même indispensable donc vous
voyez je me prête volontiers
ça n'enlève pas le danger mais c'est une
protection indispensable contrôle visuel
des sacs à main mais aussi des manteaux
les clients se prête naturellement à ce
dispositif de renforcement de la
sécurité
un protocole mis en place à la demande
de la préfecture du département et de la
préfecture de police
à l'espace saint quentin et skywest
toutes les entrées doivent être
sécurisées par un agent le dispositif
nécessite plus de personnel on a
augmenté l'effectif car on a un agent au
positionné à chaque entrée du centre
commercial hong hao tripler les
effectifs d'adp des agents de sûreté qui
procèdent à des contrôles visuels de
toute personne qui rentre dans le centre
commercial
on est à une dizaine de personnes en
plus par rapport aux au nombre de
personnes habituel depuis les attentats
de charlie hebdo du 7 janvier dernier le
plan vigipirate alerte attentats étaient
déjà en application dans ces lieux très
fréquentés
il a été durcie ces derniers jours à
vélizy 2 pendant les fêtes de fin
d'année la fréquentation quotidienne de
ce centre commercial peut monter jusqu'à
60 mille personnes le danger potentiel
est prise au sérieux par les autorités
de police et la préfecture
depuis les événements de vendredi nous
avons effectivement des effectifs
supplémentaires de police à la fois
départemental et national mais aussi des
militaires qui viennent dans le centre
commercial donc soit de façon aléatoire
soit de façon un peu plus importante
comme aujourd'hui où nous avons à des
forces de l'ordre tout l'après midi et
jusqu'à la fermeture
ces mesures relèvent avant tout de la
prudence un moyen de sécuriser les
clients depuis les attentats de vendredi
à paris une baisse de 30 % de la
fréquentation a été enregistré dans les
magasins et centres commerciaux d'île de
france et pour notre retiens notre
entretien ce soir nous recevons en
plateau ils veulent longue chambon soir
à vous vous êtes le président du coc des
skis a devancé de développement de saint
quentin en yvelines qui a pour vocation
d'apporter un éclairage citoyens aux
élus de l'intercommunalité sur les
projets du territoire alors vous êtes
ici avec nous pour nous parler de la
douzième rencontre et du connaissent qui
aura lieu samedi à l'université de
versailles saint quentin
alors le thème et la dynamique de notre
territoire au coeur du cluster de
l'innovation un thème qui est au coeur
de l'actualité donc avec paris saclay
mais aussi l'agrandissement de
l'agglomération en janvier de la
communauté de l'agglomération 50 ans les
viennent tout à fait enfin la création
d'une nouvelle communauté
d'agglomération à 12 communes pour être
précis et d'ailleurs à cette occasion
donc nous invitons ainsi d'ailleurs que
de certaines années précédentes les élus
des douze communes de l'agglomération a
participé à cette rencontre alors à
cette rencontre justement il ya les
tables rondes plusieurs conférences sur
des thèmes différents comme la
coopération entre acteurs économiques de
l'innovation la recherche universitaire
où la compétitivité sont des thèmes
voilà important que vous avez choisi
comme vous avez un peu déterminé par
rapport à l'actualité justement oui
alors le plateau de saclay donc le
cluster de l'innovation du plateau de
saclay c'est un projet dont on parle
depuis de longues années maintenant nous
arrivons à un stade où il est vous une
entre vraiment en phase opérationnelle
il va y avoir des impacts importants
pour saint quentin en yvelines pour les
entreprises de saint quentin pour les
universités écoles d'ingénieurs pour les
étudiants et pour les habitants aussi
ceux qui travaillent sur le sur le
plateau par exemple et réciproquement
donc voilà on a considéré que c'était
mon important pour pour faire le point
avec les élus sur qu'est-ce que c'est
plus précisément ce curseur de
l'innovation où on nous en sont les
projets à quel horizon par le temps et
puis comment les élus de l'agglomération
peuvent faciliter la participation la
pleine participation de 50,1 à ce
cluster donc les enjeux de cette
rencontre c'est peut-être de faire
passer des messages justement aux élus
aux acteurs justement la communauté
d'agglomération ont je pense que les
élus fallait et notamment les élus de la
de l'agglomération au niveau
communautaire sont bien bien au fait de
ces des enjeux et des prisons lien
certain nombre de projets qui existent
donc le premier enjeu de ce point de vue
là ça sera d'informer l'ensemble des
élus qui participeront donc tous les
élus communaux et des douze communes
comme une eau et communautaire de ces de
ses projets informer également
l'ensemble des élus de façon plus
détaillée que l'information qu'ils ont
pu avoir jusqu'à présent sûr qu'elle est
sur le point particulier à temps partiel
voilà par exemple par exemple qu'est ce
que c'est qu'une société d'accélération
de transfert de technologie qu'est ce
que c'est avec un incubateur plus
précisément on voit bien vaguement ce
que c'est qu'est ce que c'est qu'un pôle
de compétitivité comment tous ces
différents tous ces différents
organismes ou ses différentes façons de
travailler ensemble se recoupent se
complètent
quels sont les trajectoires d'une
entreprise ou d'une innovation depuis la
recherche
fondamental dans une université jusqu'à
jusqu'à l'innovation et sa mise sur le
marché
ça suit un certain nombre d'étapes et
donc voilà comment ça comment ça
fonctionne ça c'est le premier le
premier point et puis effectivement
ensuite comment on est
comment saint quentin en yvelines et le
tissu économique et universitaire de
saint quentin en yvelines va se
pleinement participé à tout ça et s'il
ya des conditions à remplir les
conséquences pouvoir rapport à paris
saclay pour l'université de 50 ans
deviennent alors il ya maintenant les
différents établissements d'enseignement
supérieur et les écoles dans les écoles
d'ingénieurs ou de commerce du plateau
donc et 23 ans ne croit établissements
se sont réunis maintenant dans la
l'université paris saclay donc chacune
garde déjà un peu sa personnalité ses
cursus spécifique mais en même temps il
y à une mise en commun des du corps
professoral de la conception des
maîtrise de la conception des doctorats
qui fait qu' il ya véritable de très
très fortes synergies donc l'université
paris saclay a toute sa place là dedans
sans oublier le stack a donc l'école
d'ingénieurs qui vient d'ouvrir ses
portes à saint quentin et qui forme des
ingénieurs dans le domaine de la
mobilité dans le domaine aéronautique
domaine de dd mobilité terrestre donc à
la fois du ferroviaire et de
l'automobile
et donc c'est précisément d'aider des
secteurs économiques qui sont dans
lesquelles saint quentin en yvelines et
très très développé il ya aussi des aux
problématiques sur l'été justement sens
quand on est vieux devra travailler
notamment je pense à des structures pour
accueillir tous ces gens qui vont venir
après avec le campus de paris saclay si
vous pensez à des structures du type
incubateur ou ou
ou sociétés d'accélération de transfert
de technologie effectivement ça fait
partie des questions qui pourraient être
abordés posé on pourra voir comment
d'ailleurs est ce qui a besoin de quels
sont les coopérations entre l'échelle de
saint quentin en yvelines et la grande
échelle du plateau de saclay il ya des
choses qui sont vraies affaires en
proximité des choses qui sont à faire
avec l'ensemble des acteurs du plateau
de saclay pour des raisons de taille
critique un petit peu une visibilité à
l'international donc on pourra également
aborder ces questions là lors de cette
de cette matinée si en termes de
structures notamment pour les l accueil
je vais pas reprendre des étudiants
c'est aussi un facteur important il faut
à les informer de sa les élus alors là
ce sera les élus qui vont nous dire
quels sont les plans en matière dé quoi
est ce qu'on attend de ces dossiers
rencontrer des choses vous attendent et
spécifiquement qu'ils vous disent des
messages qui vous fera peut-être rassuré
non je pense que si on sort avec les
l'ensemble des participants qui nous
disent c'était intéressant j'ai appris
beaucoup de choses deuxièmement on a
rencontré effectivement des gens qui
dirigent ce et ses essais ses structures
dont on entend parler dans la presse et
on a pu poser des questions et obtenir
des réponses sur les points précités de
concéder telle constance les ans et
représentait les questions qu'on se pose
ça sera bon je pense qu'on aura réussi
on aura atteint l'objectif que s'est
fixé ont par ailleurs bon on va aborder
aussi des questions comme la
facilitation des transports à l'échelle
du plateau de saclay donc il est clair
pour tout l'est pour tout le monde en
particulier pour le coc des skis mais je
pense aussi pour les banques un brossage
nous parle au nom du code skis que la
ligne 18 est indispensable à une 18 du
métro du grand paris est indispensable
pour relier saint quentin en yvelines à
à saclay enfin saclay à orsay
à palaiseau et que après on peut
discuter effectivement si cette liaison
doit être on aérien en souterrain en
tout cas il est important qu'elles se
fassent et qu'elle se fasse dans des
délais relativement rapproché de manière
à faciliter ces c'est la pleine
participation de 50,1 c'est cette
dynamique une dernière question avant de
terminer cet entretien alors justement
vous parlez du métro donc il n'y à
l'université paris saclay il ya
énormément de projets qui sont une
grande enquête soit lancée
vous allez peut-être recevoir l'eau
savoir après justement la réunion mais
vous pensez que vrai la communauté
d'agglomération sabotage est prête pour
ça qu'elle a les éléments sa faveur
justement ça fait très longtemps que
saint quentin en yvelines développer et
à faciliter le développement d'un tissu
économique qui est l'un des premiers de
l'ouest paris on dit que c'est le
deuxième après après après la défense il
ya présents sur le territoire
beaucoup de deux d'établissements de
recherche et de développement de très
grandes entreprises dans les secteurs
aéronautique automobile et des dents du
secteur de la défense etc
et je pense que c'est plus un coup
d'accélérateur auquel il faut réfléchir
que à la découvrir effectivement des
nouvelles façons de procéder enfin bon
il ya se mettre à jour aussi sur sur la
dynamique que va créer le second
gloucester de rang mondial eh bien merci
dont le chant d'avoir répondu à nos
questions alors je le rappelle la
rencontre et du coup des skis la
dynamique de notre territoire au coeur
du cluster de l'innovation c'est samedi
21 novembre 2015 à partir de 8h30 vous
invitez donc les élus à s'inscrire mais
c'est une rencontre qui n'est pas
ouverte au public bien sûr qui est
destiné aux élus ch mercier à vouvant
nous nous rappelons que l'important est
qu'ils aient dû s'inscrivent pour des
raisons de sécurité il ya des contrôles
évidemment s'assurer qu'on se dise on
sait qu'ils pourront avec les mesures de
sécurité aux attentes à merci beaucoup
le rôle des parents at il changé comme
on devient ton un modèle pour ses
enfants ce sont autant de questions qui
étaient abordés aujourd'hui lors du
colloque les parentalité et filiation
d'ici et d'ailleurs organisé par le
centre hospitalier jean matin jean
martin charcot de plaisir et
l'association cassiopée 350 personnes
des professionnels et des particuliers
ont participé à
cet événement sephora namadi et jérémy
tessa dare le docteur ferradji de
l'hôpital charcot de plaisir a souhaité
organiser un colloque autour des
questions de parentalité pour
accompagner les professionnels dans la
mise en place de la nouvelle unité
parents bébé on a ouvert en fait une
nouvelle unité qui s'appelle l'unité
parents bébé est en fait à la fois un
hôpital de jour on accueille des mamans
des papas et des bébés qui sont en
difficulté donc c'est un accompagnement
à la parentalité pour encourage toutes
les familles et ados c'est donc à cet
hôpital de jour il ya une équipe mobile
de perrine a donc qui se déplace au
domicile qui va dans les maternités
ce colloque est l occasion de soutenir
les professionnels dans leurs pratiques
et de permettre aux différentes équipes
de communiquer entre elles et réfléchir
ensemble
une initiative appréciée je pense que ça
parle à tout le monde en tant que
professionnel delà de la santé et puis
surtout avoir quelque chose un petit peu
sur les yvelines c'est quand même
intéressant avec la qualité des
intervenants
je pense que des problématiques disons
de deux personnes qui accouche donc les
cadets post partum
sont importantes c'est concerne chaque
chaque femme et même les universitaires
internationaux participer à cette
conférence
chacun enrichissant le débat par son
expertise différentes tous étant
confronté à une même réalité
je pense qu'avec les transformations de
nos sociétés par immigration l'arrivée
aussi importante des réfugiés la
transformation des structures familiales
par la mondialisation
repenser le rôle de la famille ses
multiples formes
en dehors d'une vision pathologie santé
ici de penser comment est-ce qu'on peut
soutenir tout ce continuum des familles
en tant que professionnel je pense que
ça c'est très intéressant mais c'est un
défi parce que les familles comme notre
monde change extrêmement rapidement
l'autre temps fort de ce colloque
s'articuler autour des problématiques de
l'autisme juvénile pour préparer les
professionnels à l'ouverture prochaine
d'une unité pour enfants autistes à
l'hôpital charcot de plaisir et prenons
la direction de guyancourt à présent où
les terrains de châteauneuf à
l'emplacement des anciennes menuiseries
maillet continue de changer de visage
après 200 nouveaux logements et un
nouveau groupe scolaire c'est une
clinique qui va voir le jour le point
sur les travaux avec mélanie potez
nouveaux visages nouveaux noms pour les
terrains de châteauneuf dans le quartier
du pont du rotois les six hectares des
anciennes menuiseries mallet sont
maintenant à quartier regroupant 200
logements une clinique verra le jour en
2016 tout ce secteur est très important
puisqu'il fait partie je le disais du
tondu routoirs et l'objectif c'était
d'arriver dans l' équilibre et dans la
mixité fonctionnelle c'est à dire avec à
la fois des espaces verts mais aussi de
l'activité mais encore des services ou
du logement c'était d'arriver dans l'
équilibre faire des nouvelles
réalisations pour dynamiser l'ensemble
du quartier du pont du rotois en
novembre 2014 c'était le groupe scolaire
triolet lurçat qui ouvrait ses portes un
bâtiment hqe le haute qualité
environnementale on avait un groupe
ancien avec des déperditions
énergétiques très forte et les travaux
qu'il aurait fallu faire en terme de
réhabilitation pour écouter pratiquement
le coût d'un groupe scolaire 9 on s'est
dit c'est l'occasion plutôt de faire un
groupe avec les nouvelles normes hqe
yeux les cibles hqe lieu très très forte
c'est quand même mieux pour l'avenir
c'est mieux pour la consommation
d'énergie
149 nouveaux logements construits par
eiffage sont en train de voir le jour
sur le site de l'ancien groupe scolaire
il devrait être livré en 2017 et comme à
chaque jeudi c'est l'heure de la
chronique sport avec notre journaliste
et michael enzi d'eurobonds sarmentelles
sanfloraine dans cette chronique je vais
vous présenter les grands rendez vous
sportifs programmées ce week-end dans le
département
allons tout d'abord prendre la direction
du vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et non il n'y
aura pas de vélo ce week-end au cyclisme
ce week-end mais bien du judo les
championnats de france par équipes de
club junior et coupe de france
individuels juniors seront organisées
samedi et dimanche dans leur centrale
pour nous parler de cet événement nous
recevons andré guardian le président de
la ligue des yvelines de judo bonsoir
bonsoir
alors il y aura neuf cents judokas ce
week-end à saint quentin en yvelines
c'est bien simple c'est à dire environ
six ans garçons et les 300 filles 300
fille et je lui garde viennent de toute
la france
toute la france et les meilleures
équipes qui ont été sélectionnés pour le
niveau national et quelles équipes
seront présentes
justement pour ce rendez vous pardon
quelles équipes seront présentes pour ce
rendez nous notre ya cinq ans une
cinquantaine l'équipe garçons et puis 39
qui prit donc pour les yvelines devons
deux équipes de trois équipes pour qu'il
y aura il y aurait 1 90
oui vraiment bien sûr il y aura sartoux
faire preuve il y aura poissy et est-ce
qu'il y aura du spectacle
celui ci avec tak j'espère bien mais
parce que bon et jugnot race et cd
rynair en herbe on va dire ça comme ça
des fuites urinaires et oui les futurs
leaders est est-ce qu'il y aura des
têtes d'affiché je sais pas est ce que
vous connaissez certains les codes de
parents puis bin moi est ce que il
devrait bien figurer ou aidant les
moyens parce que il ya les grosse
cavalerie comme 2,91 et paris donc voilà
et est ce que oui justement vous disais
il y aura des jeunes prometteurs
voilà ce que les jeunes sont classés la
sas et les 15 18 ans qui seront présents
les jeunes seront prometteur et pourquoi
et pourquoi avoir choisi du coup le
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
je pense que c'est une idée aussi de
lanig avec la communauté d'agglomération
proposé 7
cet équipement qui est formidable et
bien sûr faire connaître aussi ce
bâtiment qui peut faire autre chose que
du vélo
donc voilà et donc il ya des bénévoles
qui sont en train d'installer nous avons
tous les tatamis en ce moment
69 60 bénévoles encore
et puis bah ils sont là depuis ce matin
et demain on y sera encore et puis
dimanche à roissy pour tout ranger parce
que on installe mais après il s'était
installé il ya des camions qui sont
arrivés ce matin à athènes et à doha
semi remorques pour savoir il ya à peu
près 1500 mètres carrés de tatamis donc
il y aura huit surfaces de combat mais
sur la seconde a eu une par une avec
trois mètres de sécurité plus de sur la
partie rectangulaire de regarder 8
surface et sur les deux arrondi du drone
il y aura deux surfaces d'échappement 1
pour une surface pour les filles mais
c'est le passé pour les garçons et
environ 250 mètres carrés et est ce
qu'on peut dire que c'est un événement
exceptionnel
c'est la première fois que ça arriverait
si lisez la première fois et dans les
yvelines et dans un vélodrome et est ce
que le public est ce que le public dans
les meilleures tout simplement pour les
voir nous souhaitons que du public est
bon avec les événements est ce que les
gens sont un peu craintif mais j'espère
voir les combats durent déjà toujours
les accompagnons il ya des familles et
donc j'espère qu'il est le tarif est de
8 euros 8 euros puis gratuit pour les
ceintures noires ardue pour les
ceintures noires et est ce qu'il reste
des places
ouais y'a pas de problème les places et
on a suffisamment 1 pour l'instant on a
fait des réservations par
par internet il ya des postes le
vélodrome est assez grand pour
accueillir beaucoup de monde fera pas le
plein et les façons les réserves comment
sur le site internet du site internet ou
bien sur place a dormi sur place ma ds
que ce tournoi est aussi une pré un
prémice en fait au final aux
championnats de france seniors qui
pourrait avoir lieu l'année prochaine
avait vu juste c'est exactement ça donc
on mars prochain voilà on voir ce
concert là on a commencé en février 2015
les 2e division là on fait championnat
par équipes juniors donc en montant en
grade ou en organisation donc teddy
riner pourrait venir
le groupe de saint quentin en yvelines
oui au mois de mars c'est en négociation
combattra il devra pas avoir encore sans
titre de champion de france peut-être
une fois de plus merci à vous d'être
passé sur ce plateau je leur rappelle
les championnats de france judo juniors
sont programmées samedi et dimanche au
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
ne faudra pas manquer ce rendez vous si
vous êtes un passionné de judo à laisser
de côté les bons pour le ballon rond
on jouera ce week-end un match en retard
de france inter le match avait été
reporté le week end dernier suite aux
attentats de paris le club de versailles
qui évolue en dh jouera donc ce week-end
le 7e tour de la compétition contre
blanc-mesnil une équipe qui joue dans la
même division que les versaillais
la rencontre est programmée au stade
mont boron ce samedi à 14 heures en cas
de victoire on connaît déjà adversaires
de versailles les bleus affronteront à
domicile soit le club de dsr
mainvilliers soit les corses d'île
rousse qui évolue en cfa2 et pour les
affronter il faut déjà passer ce 7e tour
forum effectivement un mickey mais vous
savez que mieux que personne
en fait il faut prendre les matches les
uns après les autres et enfin on termine
avec du handball en nationale une
féminine les joueuses de
montigny-le-bretonneux reçoivent ce
samedi à 20h30
angoulême pour le compte de la 8e
journée du championnat lésiné montagne
qui avait très bien débuté la saison
avec deux victoires en trois matches on
dans le trou depuis plusieurs semaines à
sont sur une mauvaise série de trois
défaites consécutives ce samedi montrent
île bretonne aura la possibilité de
casser cette spirale négative
angoulême 8e de national une et juste
devant les saint-quentinoises au
classement 6e match vous intéresse il
est donc programmée au complexe sportif
pierre de coubertin à montigny samedi à
20h35
et je voulais également vous dire
florane que le boxeur d'elancourt marvin
petit ne combattra pas ce week-end à
cause des attentats de paris le il le
prouve le match qui était programmé à
levallois a donc été annulée le boxeur
que nous avions reçu en début de semaine
pour le 7-8 sport ne pourra pas défendre
sa ceinture de champion
merci beaucoup michael et on va
justement rester sur à la boxe c'est
officiel le boxing club de la verrière
l'un des meilleurs clubs français de
boxe éducative d'île de france vient
d'inaugurer sa nouvelle salle dans le
gymnase du bois de l'étang
les locaux sont désormais plus grand et
permettent donc d'accueillir plus de
licenciés un reportage
justement d'euros le boxing club de la
verrière art vie après deux mois de
fermeture pour travaux les activités de
boxe éducative ont repris depuis
novembre au gymnase du bois les temps la
salle est désormais plus spacieuse un
mur a été cassée pour doubler la
superficie l'antre des boxeurs vers
hilairois fait désormais 220 m² au lieu
de 110 un vrai plus pour le club
en termes de changement on a une plus
grande salle on a des vestiaires propres
ce qui n'était pas le cas avant dans
l'ancien gymnase avant qu'ils soient
rénovés on peut accueillir beaucoup plus
de monde
il était avons été amenés parfois être
restreint sur des groupes d'adultes
là c'est pas le cas donc on peut
accueillir encore plus de monde cette
année 62 personnes se sont inscrites au
boxing club de la verrière la plupart
des licences et viseront des titres
départementaux régionaux et nationaux
cette saison pour les boxeurs présents
dans la salle cela ne fait aucun doute
les nouvelles installations peuvent leur
permet d'accomplir leurs objectifs il ya
plus d espaces que nous mais aux bougies
rouges et quand vous frappez sur les
sacs
si on s'entraîne mais y aura plus de
gens pétition donc les gens compétition
seront plus effectif ça sera un peu
mieux pour développer les champions et
de championnat cela fera plus de
classement ça sera bien la salle n'est
pas encore complète un deuxième rim
devrait être installée à côté du premier
dans les prochaines semaines
c'est la fin de cette édition je vous
remercie de nous avoir suivis je vous
souhaite une très bonne soirée